[Music]  val schmurkovsky is in love with jenna  johnson and wants the world to know i  love to love i love to love the 31 year  old dancer recently rekindled his  romance with former flame and fellow  dancing with the stars pro jenna johnson  on saturday he made it clear he's hooked  on his quote queen posting this sweet  photo of the pair dancing with a text  overlay that read in part you have my  body mind my heart and soul's attention  i love you jenna johnson  things sure seem to be getting serious  with the pair he also used the word  eternal writing let's try and make it so  yep yep val's older brother max recently  got hitched to baby mama pita murgatroyd  could this declaration of love mean  there could be another wedding in the  schmarkovsky family they're putting a  lot of pressure on me especially my mom  my mom has been like well it's your turn  now  [Music]